forget about the Nazi white supremacists
or I'm sorry forget about the Indian
Nazis and the hispanic white
supremacists
you've also got to
pay attention to the black faces of
white supremacy that of course would be
not just Larry Elder in California but
Clarence Thomas and Tim Scott the view
the white ladies of the view very very
upset
at that white supremacist Tim Scott
running for president
who you know he's like Clarence Thomas
like Republican who believes in leaves
himself by your bootstraps rather than
to me understanding the systemic racism
that African Americans face in this
country and other minorities he doesn't
get it neither does uh Clarence right
and that's why they're Republicans yeah
I know
he doesn't get it now let me joy beija
I'm going to tell you all is almost like
a faucy voice well they're both from New
York I'm going to tell you about the
black experience in America because
Clarence Thomas
and Tim Scott they don't understand it
everyone's making fun of her for this
some people are feigning outrage some
people are genuinely offended and
everyone is mocking this idea that Joy
Behar is advancing that Tim Scott and
Clarence Thomas
could misunderstand the black experience
in America enjoy behar's defense
it's not totally absurd in principle in
this case it is
if this is absurd because Joy Behar is
totally out of touch and Clarence Thomas
and Tim Scott are far more closely
grounded to reality and they have a far
more accurate perception of the world
but it's not it's not totally out of the
question that
black people could not like black people
or something like that
black people could not like black
identity racial politics that's of
course not out of the question
saying about women who oppose feminism
is it absurd to suggest that some women
oppose feminism no the women who post
feminism have a far Keener perception of
reality than the pro-feminism women
and they're still women and they
recognize the complementarity of the
sexes
and so
they espouse a world view that is
contrary to the dominant liberal
worldview
but that's very possible
people's
views of reality moral reality physical
reality political reality
do not derive
inevitably from physical characteristics
they don't
and I fear sometimes the conservative
response to ridiculous babblings the
kind of which we just heard from Joy
Behar are to suggest that they are well
black men absolutely understand the
black experience in America and they're
by virtue of being black they totally
get it better than a white person does
that's not necessarily true
that's not you you don't need to
experience something directly to have an
understanding of it in fact sometimes
having a little bit of a remove having a
little bit of perspective can help the
reason that Tim Scott and Clarence
Thomas are right is because
not only do they have some experience
but they have highly attuned faculties
of reason and they perceive the world
correctly and they begin from correct
premises and they're just right they're
right because they're right because they
view the world correctly
they're not wrong because of the color
of their skin they're not right because
of the color of their skin
they're just right they're right because
they're on the right okay and it's a
it's a subtle distinction but we don't
want to take the bait from the libs and
fall into their their mistaken thinking
right now go to gcu.edu are you ready to
take the next step in your education but
struggling to fit traditional classes
into your busy schedule Grand Canyon
University's online programs are
designed to make earning your degree
easy and accessible no matter your age
or stage in life whether you're a busy
professional looking to advance your
career or a stay-at-home mom or dad
juggling family responsibilities gcu's
online courses give you the flexibility
that you need to learn on your own terms
I really love GCU I visited the physical
Campus of GCU years ago it was one of my
first college speeches I ever gave
I was really impressed by all of the
students there and their seriousness and
these guys are so serious and their
education was so helpful to them that I
now work with two of them two of them
are my colleagues one at the daily wire
one at Young America's foundation so GCU
man they're really they're punching
above their weight and they will
specialize in helping you fit your
bachelor's Master's or doctoral degree
into your busy day from scholarships to
customize scheduling your graduation
team led by your own GCU counselor
provides you with the personal support
that you need to succeed why wait take
your education to the next level go to
gcu.edu
gcu.edu I'm just feeling very charitable
today I don't know what to say I'm
trying to give Libs the benefit of the
doubt left and right Karine Jean-Pierre
she's getting raked over the coals
because she said Democrats don't have a
spending problem
from the White House Podium everybody
she was asked the question very directly
because we're in this debt ceiling fight
here's her answer
speaking McCarthy said yesterday in
front of the White House that the reason
why we are in this problem is because
every time Democrats wanted to make a
deal they wanted to make a deal about
spending more money so do you agree with
speaker McCarthy the Democrats have a
standing problem no
to it
no to it look
um I'll say this uh the president's
budget reduces the deficit as you as you
know by nearly three trillion dollars
over 10 years right this is a president
that believes in uh dealing with the
deficit in a real way that's on top of
the 1.7 trillion dollars that the
president has been able to reduce the
deficit the last two years so the
president takes this very seriously okay
Democrats don't have a spending problem
and then she gives these pretty weak and
dubious numbers the numbers which
almost certainly are not accurate and
the numbers which are deceptive anyway
because the spending has gotten so
insane in recent years that if you if
you dial the volume up to 75 and then
you take it back down to 65 but really
your volume should be on a one to ten
scale you can say well I reduce the
volume from the loudspeaker but it's
still insanely light it's still going to
blow out your eardrum right so
all of that is a little ridiculous
but to her point
the Democrats do not have a spending
problem
she's right
she's totally right
and I know conservatives are going to
pull their hair out over this and say
you're lying Karine Jean-Pierre how
could you possibly say such a thing she
could say such a thing because it's not
a problem to the Democrats it's the
point that Democrats don't have a
spending problem Democrats have a
spending solution Democrats solution is
we are coming up against a traditional
culture that we've done a very good job
of cracking and disassembling but
there's still a lot of common sense in
America and we haven't attained total
perfect cultural hegemony yet so how are
we going to do that we're going to wield
the power of the state in a
unprecedented way and in order to wield
the power of the state we need a lot of
money to do it and that's going to have
a double effect because if we spend a
lot of money that's also going to weaken
the order of our society which is going
to give us an opportunity to take even
more power and so the way that we're
going to get more control over the
culture is to spend an insane amount of
money
in debt America to her enemies and
Pummel our political opponents into
submission
it's very bad it's a bad thing to happen
but it's intentional it's effective it's
a solution
when are the Democrats going to address
the spending problem never never they're
never going to do that that's what
they're there for they're there to wield
that kind of power
are we going to observe that and
acknowledge that and try to turn the
political situation to our advantage are
we going to say wow golly she's crazy
imagine if the shoe were on the other
foot imagine if the shoe on the other
foot is going to be the Epitaph on The
Headstone of conservatism boy what a
clip that was make sure that you ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel
we'll see you next time